j'annonce la couleur la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui c'est une découverte une
première prise en main du nikon z6 pas
du tout un test pro je tiens à préciser
c'est une découverte voilà donc je vous
emmène avec moi sur cette découverte un
moment très sympa très conviviale et
vous allez voir on va prendre de la
hauteur
[Musique]
je vous emmène aujourd'hui ici la
boutique sélection photos vidéos le shop
photo pour parler nikon d'un petit
boîtier là avec un objectif plutôt sympa
c'est le 7 6 on va laisser un petit truc
je ne suis pas un spécialiste de la
photo se fait plus de la vidéo aux en
douterait je ne connais pas beaucoup ni
comme assez peu je connais la marque est
plutôt bien initiation découverte on va
se faire une petite soirée sympa
shooting au troisième étage de la tour
eiffel
normalement c'est plutôt pas mal devrait
pas pleuvoir regardez l'état du ciel ça
va bien se passer
j'ai moi qu'est ce qui est bien dans ce
boîtier
venez vous êtes c'est alors qu'est ce
qui est bien je dirais que peut-être
déjà le design on revient sur un
mirrorless c'est vraiment très pour
nikon qu'il fasse un qui laisse pas la
concurrence pas à sony qui a son
importance et une belle proposition ça
fonctionne un peu comme les sauniers
exactement fait c'est pour moi la
réponse de nikon pour sony pas là est
fini
c'est une très très bonne réponse le
boîtier les bouillir si les couilles
bien qu'un point fort de cet objectif
avant d'aller sur l'appareil photo
c'est un 14 35 30 il ya eu nos clients
fait il est tout petit ouais on n'est
pas à 14 journées revient en force et en
position le décompte des logs et il
passe à 14 revient un format un peu plus
grand yes c'est ça je trouve ça cool de
mettre ça après avoir un truc complet ok
on va le tester pour voir laquelle toi
ce que ça des bonus tout à l'heure en
début on va histoire un petit shooting
avec ce boîtier la laub à se mettre pas
mal gardien brestois retour d'un peu
plus près on attend peut pas y accéder
comme ça la tour eiffel est un peu
galère mais voyez là haut ça devrait
bien se passer
[Musique]
torres en soirée on arrive ça se mérite
la torre pellemans pendant le we alors
on a déjà pas mal
deuxième niveau de la tour eiffel on va
sentir le troisième cd chatrier où je
vous le dis j'ai voulu dire si ge
[Musique]
on voit là on arriver tout en haut le
toit fait je crois que là on peut
difficilement faire plus haut dans paris
normalement des dents le point culminant
pour tester ce petit vote normalement
c'est un nikon france et ça ça a l'air
pas mal je crois que c'est tout ce que
je peux dire on est avec elle et
christian denis coefficient alors on
n'est pas mal quand même pouvoir
discuter tout ça roule la tour eiffel on
est bien c'est vraiment un super moment
on a beaucoup de chance en plus le
soleil commence à se coucher donc c'est
vraiment magnifique
on est vraiment pas mal alors tu peux
parler de 7,6 parce que moi j'ai eu des
coups je le connaissais pas il est sorti
à quelques temps de ça et bien
effectivement il est sorti fin d'année
dernière on a commencé par sortir le z7
avec un capteur de 45 millions viennent
appareil plutôt haute définition est
sorti fin novembre début décembre le zi6
son petit frère avec 24 millions de
pixels un appareil plus polyvalent
encore avec des montées en sensibilité
un petit peu plus importante et une
cadence de tir plus importante voilà
mais ceux ci n'ont les produits restent
strictement les mêmes que ce soit en
termes d'ergonomie en termes de visée
en termes de construction c'est
rigoureusement les mêmes produits moi
j'ai eu des couilles le sexy si les
puces destinées aux photos va parce que
les vidéastes la plus utilisée aussi
bien évidemment c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui photo vidéo s'est confondue
c'est un appareil avec énormément de
possibilités vidéo ou encore plus les 6
et 7 du fait de son capteur de 25 x l
non c'est vraiment une touche photo
vidéo on passe c'est vraiment ultra 28
préface il est très facile avec des
optiques qui suivent toujours puisqu'on
a des optiques plus hâtive pas donc
fluide en vidéo c'est vraiment le top
bien qu'ils et inaki plutôt ce projet
faisait de 6 franchement tout le monde à
tous les amateurs de leur entrée dans
l'univers de la photo vidéo alors les
gens qui veulent entrer dans l'univers
de la photo de la vidéo mais sa voix
était très très bien construit qui
correspond aux besoins des
professionnels aux besoins des amateurs
avertis qui amenez vos produits et voilà
c'est vraiment appareil à venir et voilà
en termes de construction etc
c'est vraiment un super chouette à part
s'il devait y avoir un seul point mettre
en avant ça serait quoi c'est un rapport
aux autres sa nouvelle baïonnette quoi
c'est tout le secret sa nouvelle voie
youn est avec un tirage ou mécanique
réduit c'est un anglais 120 degrés ça
c'est vraiment la grosse innovation de
nikon vient c'est toi c'est quoi ces
trucs là naquit senti qu'ils font
clignoter la touriste ne voyez donc la
ruhr super super et bravo et à
l'organisation c'est beaucoup en fait
moi ta boutique année à saint lazare 4
rue de la borde exactement de l'accord
rappelle ma non sélection photos vidéo
merci beaucoup ta organiser un événement
qui très sympa avec nicole je suis
content que ça vous plaise aussi bref
permet de découvrir le prend mal et si
surtout qu'a donc chouette boîtier
qu'est ce que tu dirais toi comme un
avantage aux et 6 la taille ont réduit
la taille on a une belle bague qui fait
qu'on a une aura de l'entrée de lumière
qui est bien plus importante que sur les
reflex d'accord donc on peut avoir des
autistes verte à 4
qu'ils soient apparemment moins
lumineuses et pourtant on a beaucoup de
lumière principalement les
on peut dire sur annaba un appareil
comme ça à regarder ses impression
d'avoir là vous avez le laser fin le
faisceau lumineux kaki par deux de la
torre seul qui fait tout le tour et le
voir depuis la tour eiffel c'est hyper
impressionnant dans la puissance du truc
[Musique]
c'est bien la tour eiffel rom est trop
de monde et il fait froid ou trop de
monde l'idée aujourd'hui c'est juste de
découvrir prendre en main voilà
partageant pas du coup moi je ne suis
pas un grand spécialiste connaissent pas
particulièrement ni nikon ni le matériel
je tourne avec du matériel de battage
pratique c'est pas le dire trop fort
mais bon tout ça c'est intéressant donc
c'est pas la vidéo la plus vue voilée
tous ces data gov et au salut bonjour
enfin cette vidéo merci monsieur
mais venez me suis regardé sa liste
comment trouvez vous aujourd'hui si vous
regardez vous là c'est là c'est ça vous
regardez là bas quand le match à la 4e'
ça va ça va être dur envers thomas j
ouais je suis athée c'est pourquoi ces
révisions donc ça c'est dès cet
après-midi à droite il va s'étendre sur
petit nikon et six découvertes c'est pas
forcément la vidéo la plus technique
dessus merci au revoir bisous c'était
cool et c'était très instructif
découverte sympathique parce que je
connaissais pas ce boîtier alors je suis
pas beaucoup plus avancé mais je
laissais je trouve intéressant donc à
tester beaucoup plus en profondeur voilà
dites moi si ça vous botte ça vous
intéresse tout ça tout ça tout ça merci
nikon merci tout le monde mon cjb gains
à bientôt
m